the plumber is going portable as Apple
has announced Nintendo will be launching
a Mario game for your iphone called
Super Mario run I'm Dave and welcome to
this mobile games 1 news update the game
isn't all to run in which mario
automatically Sprint's from left to
right with players needing to tap the
screen to make him jump over gaps and
collect coins as the game progresses
there will be power-ups that change the
way this mechanic works but the ultimate
goal is to get the flagpole as quickly
as possible in a press release published
after games announcement Miyamoto said
for the first time ever players will be
able to enjoy a full fledged Super Mario
game with just one hand giving them the
freedom to play while riding the subway
or my favorite eating a hamburger an app
store listing for Super Mario run has
also appeared further explaining the
game's features Super Mario run offers
three different game modes the first
mode features challenging courses for
you to complete in the second mode you
challenge the play data of other
people's completed courses you compete
to see who can finish the course for the
most style in the third mode you can
create your own Mushroom Kingdom using
toys collected by playing the first two
game modes Super Mario run is being
developed with Miyamoto as Lee creator
for Nintendo and mobile game studio DNA
which Nintendo partnered with for me
tomo this is the second of five mobile
games nintendo has pledged to launch by
march 2017 with games based on animal
crossing and Fire Emblem also known to
be in development see samara rome will
be available in december 2016 are you
excited for Mario's debut on smartphones
or would you prefer a new 3d mario game
to be announced let us know in the
comments section below or you can find
me on Twitter at a regular Dave and for
more both Mario and Nintendo keep it
gamescom